[Music]
hello everyone to the cloud spinner
one-on-one session you might hear it
already this session will be in English
so I don't say I will not be offended if
you choose another session if you don't
like me speaking in English
I'm Robert Kubus I'm a developer
advocate for the Google cloud platform
so what does that mean we are basically
the bi-directional interface between you
guys who built on top of the cloud
platform and the developer said build
the cloud platform so that's also why
you see there my twitter handle please
reach out with how what you're building
on on cloud platform we like to feature
things if you have constructive feedback
please reach out as well we try to
improve the developer experience further
and further now what am I going to talk
about today is first I gonna basically
step back a couple of years and give a
brief history of like how we came up
with spanner and why and then explain
what cloud spanner is in particular I
will show you some demos and how you can
get started as well so what is spanner
going back about twelve years like to
2005 and Google's business was on the
back of a shard admirers girl right so
every dollar that we made with with
advertising and our AdWords system or
SPECT buy a shorted MySQL system that
was charted by a customer ID and then
occasionally we had to [ __ ] this
system to be able to grow even further
and further now the last reshot that we
did took several years for matter of
fact and at that point we were saying
like okay we can't do that any longer we
like our business can't grow at the pace
that we growing and keeping all the
qualities with being on back of a firm
shortage shorted traditional database
system so that's where we came up with
spanner we needed to build a system
which has a lot of the qualities of a
traditional database system but has on
top of the
things like horizontal scaling right so
we had a lot of customers we were
growing very quickly from a 10 million
dollar business a year 2 billion dollar
business a year and we were dealing with
with people's money we had customers we
had budgets that they could set we had
like partners agencies and things like
that we couldn't work with a system that
relies on eventual consistency because
this would mean that we could lose data
and we could lose money also like every
like this system like Google is a 24/7
365 business its operating around the
world and we cannot deal with any kind
of downtime every time like we are down
with our systems our back-end systems it
basically means a lot of millions or
thousands of the dollars that we are
losing and our customers as well so
prior to to spanner there was no such a
system that where every basically could
do updates of our database system with
no downtime where we could do day schema
changes with not no down times and
things like that now how does it relate
to to cloud spanner
let's step like 10 3 10 years later
roughly and what we do with cloud
spanner is basically making this
internal system that we build for which
our business relies on we make this
available to all of you so that means
like you have the same performance and
scalability and consistency that we have
of our internal spanner it's the same
team that builds it plus the team that
builds the integration with our cloud
for things and it's the same team that
keeps the reliability of the system like
that the system that we use internally
as well as the system that you get to
use on the cloud platform so what was
really important here was that this is
like one system which goes into the
direction of a cloud native system so
it's a fully managed system you
basically can do with click setup you're
your spanner instance and you can scale
it transparently and also what is really
important when we built the system
internally is people understood the
to work with a MySQL post quest with a
relational database system which has
like asset transaction and it's much
harder to deal with a system it has like
the only low-level consistency or
eventual consistency writing it apps on
top of that especially financial apps is
really hard because you have to build
basically your transactional layer on
top of this so we needed a system which
has like the traditional semantics
offered relational database system so
spanner comes with these traditional
semantics as well we also wanted to
integrate with existing tools and things
like that so you can basically under
stress college skills and work spanner
like with the familiar SQL language
now a really important thing for us as
well is I mentioned like no downtime and
24/7 business we needed a really a
reliable system we needed a system where
we can have high availability so if any
like hardware failure is there that the
database doesn't go down and that we do
by like having a synchronous replication
of the data in spanner and having high
reliability with this and I go in a
little bit more detail what that
actually means and what you also get
with putting your applications on cloud
spanner is a system which has been
battle tested within Google our Edwards
system relies from the starter on it but
also nowadays a lot more of the internal
and external apps that we have rely
actually on top of spanner so for matter
of fact if you look at who without
platform the control plane which
basically tracks everything when you
start GC instances and things like that
the control plane is based on on top of
cloud spanner now what Google is really
committed to is being the open cloud so
we try to like really hard to do have as
least lock-in as possible so we try to
integrate open standards build like a
like a multitude of client libraries so
that you can integrate with your
applications that you already have
existing so we have client libraries in
Java Python
no js' and there are more languages
coming up we also have like the Chia PC
stop as as open source so you can build
your own life languages own online stops
as well as a mod we also provide
currently read-only JDBC driver to
integrate with tools like business
intelligence tools and things like that
what was really important for us as well
for a cloud-based solution is from the
start to integrate cloud spanner of
things like audit logging Identity and
Access Management and decryption on rest
of your data also if you look at the SQL
language standards that is used within
Google cloud platform it wasn't always
that we had a coherent story there so we
put actually a lot of effort in in the
recent months and years to standardize
on the SQL dialect that we are using
throughout our products and cloud
spanner uses also SQL ANSI 2011 as for
instance bigquery is using with some
extensions on top of this now we get
asked a lot like how there's cloud
spanner compared to a traditional
relational database system or like a non
relational database system like so
called no SQL database now if you
compare cloud spanner to a traditional
relational database system you basically
look at schema SQL and consistencies and
both of these systems like a traditional
relational database and spanner provide
this right where they divert is
availability now you can build a high
available system with a traditional
database system but usually what that
means is you you are like create like a
read replica you create a failover you
have to manage all these and basically
with a read replica you free up your
master node a little bit of the read
like workload to get more performance
towards a write workload but your
traditional relational database is the
only vertical staling database now what
it also means like if you have a
failover instance or read replicas in a
charted system you need to manage all
these you need
to manage like updates of your systems
you might have to fail over your master
to fail over instance when you want and
take down your your master and update
the hardware or they update the you OS
which basically means even if it is
planned you incur a downtime all right
this is not the case with spanner
we don't have downtime of spanner
the other thing is if you look at like
scalability as mentioned in a in a
traditional database system you
basically have vertical scalability -
and you can to some extent go like
higher and higher and seems like it's
wait till your cloud provider provides a
bigger machine and you hope that they
provide a bigger machine while you're
reaching the ceiling and you can do
things like read replicas to free your
master from this read workload but you
still have a ceiling in terms of
scalability if you compare cloud spanner
to non-relational database system like
you already see in the beginning like
most of the new SQL systems don't have
like a rich at schema they don't have
like necessarily SQL support might come
with an addition or some of them partly
for providing SQL but it's not as like
you are used to it from a MySQL post
custom and what's really important is
the consistency now we have in certain
no SQL database system the possibility
to basically tweak your consistency
model but it comes with trade-offs it
comes with trade-offs of like
scalability and and performance of your
system now you don't need to make these
trade-offs with low it's better it's
really performant out-of-the-box for
read and write so what are the typical
workloads that we see with spanner that
we have seen in our EAP and now since
spanner is beta and GA currently is
actually re state GA we have seen
multitude of applications that are
moving to spanner and I want to take out
three that are really important and
which is things like where the spanner
has like really the things so I
mentioned off like scalability now if
you look at a system in terms of
scalability before you're right and you
read scalability that's where well
spanner is really strong you can
horizontal scale and you basically scale
your write and read very seamlessly so
that's one thing where you don't have
these dis limits that you have one which
is a traditional system another really
important thing is with spanner even
though it's a horizontal scalable system
you have transactional you have acid and
you have strong consistency actually we
are really apparent about this in the
sense that we have external Co lies
ability as our consider isolated a
consistency model in spanner now
especially if you look at like a
financial mark
FinTech or things like that this is
really important that you have this
these capabilities and that transactions
can span rows and multiple tables you're
not limited to a certain part of your
database
what is also a really strong use case
for spanner is a global data plane very
basically spanner comes in as a highly
available system spanner is by design a
highly available system if you get a
regional set up it comes with nine four
nines of availability which is like 4.38
four minutes 38 seconds of downtime a
month now if you use a multi regional
setup which comes later this year you go
down to 26 seconds of of down times a
month which translates to five nines of
of availability SLA now how does spanner
actually chief that like how does
spanner look like under the hood so if
you look at spanner if you like by
OneNote from us you basically get a node
which is replicated in three zones in a
regional instance so you have your
regional instance and you have your
replication of your compute and your
storage in three zones now what's really
important here is that storage and
compute are separated in a way that they
are independent from each other so you
can scale compute and storage
independent from each other so what does
it mean what all the all these terms if
you look at spanner you start with an
instance
that's something that you basically when
you create your Spano database you start
with an instance where you define
like with region do I want to have my
stem spanner instance in and how many
notes do I want to have for my from my
spanner instance now in the spanner
instance you can create up to 100
databases and in this database you can
create a multitude up to 2-under like
hundreds of of tables now this these are
the concepts that are used to form a
traditional database system and these
are the concepts that you are visible to
you now behind the scenes we we actually
split these tables and so-called splits
are in contiguous key ranges so based on
your primary key we basically choose
contiguous key ranges and split your
your table that enables us to do the
horizontal scalability for write and and
and reads so if you look you basically
have your splits that are replicated
three times in each zone you have your
notes and for this example right now we
look at only one note so you buy one
note from us this is replicated in three
zones now what is really important is
that to be strong consistent you really
have to make sure that only one is
writing basically to a certain split and
it has in control is in control of that
data piece now what we use in in spanner
is so-called practice algorithm which is
a majority voting to vote leader in my
in in that group so we have basically
apexis groups spends all three zones and
they're basically based on on the split
so you have for each like the replicas
you choose one leader in your paksas
group now if you know and you come from
a distributed world you know like making
sure that you actually have only one
leader at any point in time requires a
lot of communication now communication
is expensive and that would basically
mean that you slow down your database so
what Google did is they invented
actually a system which
moves the need of a lot of these
communication and the system is called
through time so what is through time so
if you compare your watches with your
neighbor and you go out and you come
back in five minutes
if you have really detailed watches and
like milliseconds your watches will have
drifted from each other
the reason is like items fear extreme
raise it is temperature it's pressure
all kinds of things that that interfere
with how fast your clocks are running so
keeping clocks in sync across oceans and
across data centers is a really really
really hard problem now what Google did
is they built a system based out or
consisting of atomic clocks and GPS
synchronization to synchronize the
clocks in all data centers now it's not
a wall clock time that you get actually
one timestamp which is really smart here
is actually you get a range you get kind
of like a range of time and what is this
what is this range so you get a lower
bound and an upper bound timestamp the
lower bound timestamp means that this
time has definitely pasts everywhere in
the world the upper bound times them
means that this time stem has definitely
not passed everywhere in the world and
by the technology that we are used we
can basically get this this interval
down to a couple of milliseconds and by
having this global wall torque time we
can make sure that we have exactly one
leader for split at any point in time
and by that we can make sure that we
have strong consistency in the strengths
actions that we that we are running in
in in spanner now let's show a little
bit like how that looks like when you
look actually at a query that runs
against lao-tzu spanner so in this case
I have I want to do a consistent read
which basically means I really want to
have the latest data at that point so
what I start with is my client sends a
request and it goes into a front end
which figures out where the responsible
split
for this query yes so there is a
transparent routing basically happening
now in this case we are routed to a
slave or like a replica which is closest
to us and that replica basically says
okay this is a strong read so I need to
check if I have the latest data so it
will do a request to the to the leader
of that split and it will get back yeah
you have the latest data and then we
basically can serve that data from from
the slave on the read replica now in the
case that you have actually not the
latest data so we asked basically the
leader like do I have the latest data
the leader will respond back no you
don't have the latest data but just just
wait a couple of milliseconds and you
will have it so it's not that with this
request we are sending actually the data
most likely at the point that we are
asking the leader if we have the latest
data the data is already in flight to
the replicas so that we will basically
be in sync at a later point so what it
basically happens is the slaves will
wait out at that time till it's up to
date to the timestamp when the request
came in and then once the time is waited
out we can respond with the data now the
thing is what like in there might be use
cases where you don't want to stress
your leaders basically with these calls
to check if I have the latest data there
might be use cases where you can read
stale data where you okay to read stale
data and especially if you look at a
multi regional set up where you have
replication low-poly this might be a
good thing to actually answer really
quickly to your clients now what how can
you do this the way to do this is the so
called use stale queries where you give
a time bound of how much stillness you
allow so in this case I basically say
alright I want to have data which is at
maximum 15 seconds old now this comes in
again through one of our reach replicas
and replay apricot checks basically time
send of the data that it has for this
data that was requested and checks
against like the the times time parent
and
sieze okay I have data which is
definitely newer than the timestamp
balancer I can return and respond
directly without involving the leader at
all
now the next concept is read why
transaction and just what I mentioned
what I mentioned before if you saw like
the read-only transaction that I've
talked in the beginning it didn't had
any locks that we so read only
transaction can actually work without
setting any locks and slowing down my my
read Y transactions now in a readwrite
transaction what I basically do is when
I when the request comes in through my
front and that does the routing the
routing is directly done to the leader
of my paksas group now the leader
acquires locks and sends back the query
results for the read that I'm doing in
my in my transaction now then I'm doing
something a to calculation I'm adding
some money to it or things like that and
I'm sending back basically the write
that I want to do with the update of the
data now in that case we have the locks
already required what we do is we were
sending the right to our read replicas
and as soon as a majority comes back
from this read replicas which includes
myself the leader at that point I can
basically say okay the data is going to
be committed so I can respond already to
to my client and say like ok I can
respond and release the locks and any
replicas that hasn't responded up to
that point basically will catch up all
right so I mentioned that spanner is
based on like the semantics that you're
used to from a relational database
system be it MySQL be it Postgres or any
of the major database vendors now you
have like very familiar constructs you
have tables with columns which have like
the standard SQL data types so it's
strongly typed and what you can do here
for instance we have a singles table and
albums table where you can define
primary keys now there's one thing you
don't have foreign key constraints in in
spanner but you have
different concept which is kind of like
a foreign key constraint - - which we
call interleave tables now what are
interleave tables as just talking about
spanner being a distributed system
horizontally distributed system and
anytime you need to do any communication
to get your data together to do a
response that basically means time more
spend for actually getting your query
results to your clients so if you have
certain queries where you want to
co-locate the data where you basically
want to do some kind of a pre join you
can use the construct of in the leaf
tables which basically ensures the
collocation of of that data and very
straightforward to do this you basically
do the singers table here and then the
elbows say albums table and defined and
this the albums table is an interleaved
table of your singles table now there
are certain schema things that you can
do and there are certain things that you
should not do so it's like empty
patterns that are used to do in a
vertical scalable database system are
here actually hurting if you move to to
spanner so I want to point out a couple
of those one is if you use I mentioned
that spanner tables are split up by
contiguous key ranges now you can
imagine if you use a monotonic
increasing or decreasing primary key you
basically always end up in as one split
if you basically append it to this table
so you are hot spotting on that one
split and that restricts your
scalability now basically the way that
we get right and reads veil ability is
by moving around these splits that I
mentioned earlier through different
compute nodes so if we see like one of
the compute nodes it's very busy we
basically take away that split and give
it another one and by that we have the
scalability and reads and writes now if
you use monotonic increasing primary
keys and that always goes to the same
split you're basically hot spotting on a
part which we cannot dispute any further
so also don't use timestamp for this for
instance another thing is where you also
want to be careful is I just mentioned
the technique of interleaving but use it
in a way that you don't over interleaf
because this means it also means like
data collocation means you can also
hotspot on certain things in your tables
if you overuse interleaving so here's an
example of what I just talked about so
if you have for instance here like a
time scent that we use and if we insert
like always with the time stamp as like
our primary key it all goes to like one
one one split now how can I avoid this
so one good practice to avoid this is
using you IDs so we recommend using your
IDs version 4 as primary keys now there
might be certain situations where you
cannot do this so what you also can do
is you can use a charting key in front
of your of your time stamp if you need
to use times than for instance or
monotonically increasing numbers you can
basically use a shortened key in front
of it to accommodate that another thing
what you want to do if you move to
spanner is really designing your schema
on your primary workloads so that your
primary workload performs the best so
here's an example of how we basically
prepare prefixed our our primary key
with a charting ID and by that we can
split up the the inserts into multiple
spits and we can move these bits around
to model are two different compute nodes
to have the scalability now we switch to
the demo computer to to get started with
cloud spanner your first stop is
cloud.google.com slash spanner and this
gives you like all the information and
like like high level what spanner is but
also all the pointers to client
libraries and things like that what I
want to point out here is on the bottom
of this entry page you see things like a
comparison of what it's like how does
cab for instance play into spanner
that's defeated or not things like that
so Eric Brewer took a take on explaining
spanner and the tap capturing and like
how to times plays into that also what
really nice and really create material
is if you come from chartered my scale
or charted postcards we have cloud spent
a case studies which explain you how you
can do this transition from such a
system to to spanner and how you have to
take care of certain things so Chris led
one of our early access partners
basically a customers did the transition
from a charted MySQL through spanner and
they explained in detail what kind of
considerations say they had to do now
for the remainder of my demo I want to
go back to the schema that you saw
earlier today in the in the keynote so
what we had there is a scenario of a
ticket sale system and in this ticket
sale system it's really important that
we sell each ticket or exactly once so
that's why we choose to use spanner for
that use case now we wanted to have it
as somewhat really realistic
so actually we came up with some schema
to make it somewhat realistic so what
you can see here is it all revolves
around like events so you have multiple
events which we categorize can
categorize in a multi event like a tour
of a singer or star or things like that
and then we have venues these venues
have different seating categories like
general admission or VIP or premiums and
things like that
now these these seating categories we
actually choose to interleave directly
in the menu because we have to fetch
them very often together and then we
have different prices for our events so
we actually do connect ticket categories
to seating categories and then have all
our tickets in our database so in this
database that we showed in the in the
keynote today we had up to put 1 billion
tickets actually in the database that
you can solve cell now while this
database is running I can actually do
things like running queries so in this
case I have a query we
it looks at the seats available for
events that are going on right now till
midnight today so you see it down here
and my rare clause I'm looking at like
okay what's happening right now to
midnight or actually 2:00 a.m. and I
look for all the events that are going
on in in in Spain so now when I run this
I will see that this will actually take
a while and I might look at it and say
like okay like this is not actually for
transactional system where I need to do
this check like really quickly eight
seconds is definitely too long to do
this now what you can do with spanner is
actually directly in in our cloud
console you can inspect your queries and
you can check like what is the query
plan what you're basically used to from
any other major database where you can
actually see like what is the database
doing behind the scenes and as you can
see here we are actually like scanning a
lot of rows and scanning a lot of rows
is pretty expensive so what you can do
as like in like the major database
systems is to actually give the
optimizer a degree optimizer some hints
what to do so in this case I have a an
index defined on on my event table which
will help me to boil down the the data
that I'm actually reading so in this
case I use like that's one of these
extensions where I say okay I want to
force the index use event by day and you
see like right now it's coming back in
much faster in 1.4 seconds and if we
look at the explanation you see that the
row scan falls down a lot so you have
the possibility to also tweak your
crease and in that way now I have a play
database and I want to show you really
quickly how you can get started for
instance with Java and and
your own queries with Java and spanner
so if you set up your environment the
first thing that you need you need to
basically authenticate against against
spanner and if you have G cloud
installed on your machine or if you run
your workload on GCE
you have something called application
default credentials and so you see here
I just do Google credentials don't get
application default and basically it
uses my context that I'm running this
application in and that's all the
authentication for me so that's pretty
quick the next thing that I want to do
is I I need to define like which which
instance owner do I want to talk to and
which database do I want to talk to so
very standard the project is taking from
the application default credentials so I
don't have to define that here so I only
define the database the instance name
and the database name the next thing
that I need is I basically need to start
up my my database line so in this case I
just basically get my database with all
the information that I just mentioned
like project ID instance ID and database
ID and then I can basically start
running transaction so the first thing
that I'm going to do is I gonna show you
a read-only transaction so in this case
I basically get from my diet my database
client and say like okay I just want to
do one run off of a query so I get a
single-use read-only transaction so this
doesn't keep this transaction open it
basically gives you the possibility to
run one we get the results back and the
transactions over we are using in this
case a read-only transaction because I
don't want to acquire any locks on on
spanner as I mentioned before now we
basically do our query in this case I'm
just getting all events that are
happening right now so like yeah which
basically all the events like ten events
that are rich are open for sale right
now and I need to of course go through
my result set so result and like as you
are used to from
iterate able collections you basically
can just iterate through your result set
and print out the the result so in this
case as you can see in my select
statement I select the multi event ID
and the name so I just get string and
you can choose either the column name
the column in your in your SQL query or
you can choose actually the column index
so in my case I'm choosing the column
index and and I'm running it and fingers
crossed if I'm successful we'll come
back and basically this was not all
right don't fail
of course alright so here in this case
basically I'm executing the read I
getting my multi-event IDs back and I
get my body event so nice
ok the next thing that I want to do is I
want to do a read/write transaction now
we have the exact same thing that I just
showed I not going to type with all this
again up to the point that we basically
get the client and then you see
something here called mutations so what
are mutations the construct in spanner
is everything which basically changes
data is called a mutation we have a
couple of restrictions on mutations so
one thing is your transaction shouldn't
be bigger than 10 megabytes so this feed
pods is about 1 1 megabyte for per
transaction another thing is you
shouldn't change more than 20000 cells
in your in your transaction what does
that mean a cell now you have a table
for instance with five columns five
attributes now if you change the table
if you have no index is defined and you
insert a row in this in this table of
five columns you end up with five
mutations now if you have an index
defined on your on your table which
basically in the indices two columns of
your table then you have another two
mutation so if you insert an row and you
have a table with five columns and an
index which index two columns you end up
with seven mutations now the limitation
is to not have more than 20,000
mutations within one transaction now
what I'm doing here is basically I'm
getting a UID I am setting a name
country code email address and adding
like in this case I'm not having any
tickets so I'm adding now there and I'm
just running this and that basically
inserts an account for me so as you can
see here if I go in preview I have like
in this case three counts added to my
database now if I wanted to an update
this was a write only in section now if
I want to do an update are basically to
a read write transaction and in this
case what I'm
starting with what I'm getting is I'm
using so-called transaction runner and
this transaction run over to give it you
give it a basically a runnable where you
like abstract array you give it a
basically function to execute why are we
doing this the reason for this is you
basically give the client a function to
execute and if a client will by itself
do the redo if the transaction fails
so you basically give that through our
client and you don't have to care about
redo and rerunning your transactions in
case that they fail in this case i'm
basically reading all the accounts with
with my email address and i'm updating
my name on on this on these accounts so
once this is run as you can see here i
can go back to my preview and you will
see that the name has changed in all in
all three rows now last but not least
what i want to show is if you i want to
clean up as well of course and the thing
the way that you can select data within
within with the client library it's not
only per SQL you can also use to read
api's and for instance here in this case
i want to delete all the data that i
have in my account table so i use the
key set all where i should not use it an
SQL statement i actually use a mutation
where say like i wanna have just
everything in this table based on the
key set all and just delete this and
once we redo this you will see it so
basically you can choose between SQL and
our read api is to work with spanner
once we go back and we go here we will
see that all the data is being gone all
right going back to the slides
so how does spanner compared to all the
other products that you might have heard
about today or you might her in the
future or you did hear about in in in
the past so there's a multitude of
different kind of storage and database
products under GCP so if you look at
like a more in memory database and
you're writing your applications in App
Engine you can use App Engine memcache
for instance now if you have something
we don't need the high availability the
horizontal scalability for write and
reads and the database which can grow
across terabytes of data so our example
the demo database that we had had 30
terabytes of data if you look at like a
traditional vertical scalable database
system you basically end up with a
couple of terabytes that you can scale
to and then it gets really difficult so
if you don't have a lot of data if you
don't need like a high available system
and if you want to like you run
applications that are already well
integrated with things like MySQL or
Postgres then you can use our managed
cloud SQL service which provides you
MySQL or postcard solution which with
the possibility to read replicas and
fail overs and things like that now if
you need the things that I just
mentioned horizontal scalability high
availability things like that then you
want to start with spanner now if you
don't need the relational data model if
you want them more like a new SQL data
model and you don't need to
transactional consistency and s it come
as a semantics that spanner and cloud
SQL flavors are providing then we have
cloud datastore for like a more document
based hierarchical model or if you look
at a more like system where you have
like basically key value based and you
have cloud BigTable which provides you
tremendous write and read performance in
single-digit milliseconds for like a
really high throughput now a datastore
and cloud BigTable are fully managed
solutions
which are in a way like you don't think
about machines anymore they scale the
few needs from start to like terabytes
and petabytes of data now if you have
non structured data you're looking at
cloud storage for instance and if you're
looking into a data warehouse system
where you'd want to do analytics with a
more full fledged SQL support than you
look into into a big query for instance
now there are a couple of decisions that
you can make along the way if you at the
point where like okay which system
should I use it's basically a
reiteration of the slide that we saw
earlier where you basically can ask
yourself a couple of questions in terms
of your data structures if not you can
go to cloud storage if you need a mobile
sdk you can go to firebase and use
firebase storage to have like all the
integrations with ios and android and a
lot of web SDKs now if your data is
actually structured and you want to do
analytics on top of it
then you're looking more to the things
like cloud BigTable and bigquery if you
don't like know your primary workload
it's not analytical then you make the
decision between relational versus non
relational right in the relational case
you go to cloud SQL or spanner and the
non-relational case you go to cloud
datastore or firebase DB and with that
I'm done with my talk and thank you very
much for your attention
[Applause]
[Music]